lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en cómo cambia el valor de una
expresión conforme la variable que está
en esta expresión cambia comencemos con
una expresión sencilla digamos que
tenemos la expresión de 100 menos x como
cambiaría a esta expresión conforme x
aumenta o se incrementa
x se incrementa y como siempre los
invito a que traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta
pausa en el vídeo traten de resolverlo y
después regresen para ver la solución
que tenemos aquí hay un par de maneras
en las que podemos pensar en esto
podemos decir bueno aquí tengo estos 100
a los que le estoy restando x
y conforme x se incrementa
voy a estar restando cantidades cada vez
más grandes de x y si estoy restando
cantidades o valores cada vez más
grandes pues me va a quedar un valor
cada vez más pequeño así que todo esto
de aquí
va a disminuir
y si quieren ver esto de una forma un
poco más concreta podemos probar algunos
valores aquí por ejemplo aquí voy a
poner los valores para x vamos a hacer
una pequeña tabla de aquí
aquí tengo xy de este otro lado voy a
tener 100 menos x y voy a tomar algunos
valores de xy voy a hacer que vayan
aumentando por ejemplo x que sea 0 va a
ser 50 y también va a ser 100 bueno
cuando x vale 0 100 menos x pues va a
ser 100 menos 0 no le voy a quitar nada
me va a quedar aquí 100 cuando x vale 50
100 menos 50 va a ser igual a 50 y
cuando x es igual a 100 100 menos 100
pues va a ser cero y aquí queda muy
claro que conforme x aumenta o se
incrementa este 100 menos equis va a
disminuir así que conforme x y lo
abrevió aquí se incrementa vemos que si
en menos x va a disminuir
y lo abre vio aquí hagamos esto con
algunas expresiones diferentes por
ejemplo se me ocurre tener 5 / x + 5 y
ahora está x va a disminuir
y además sabemos que x es positivo y es
mayor que cero así que x es mayor que
cero así que aunque se vaya disminuyendo
siempre va a permanecer mayor que sea a
lo mejor esta es una situación en la que
x disminuye de 10 a 5 o de 1.100.000
pero siempre se va a quedar por encima
del cero pero siempre va a permanecer
positiva conforme disminuye bueno
pensemos en esto esto disminuye así que
vamos a estar dividiendo entre valores
positivos que se hacen cada vez más
pequeños y conforme tenemos números
positivos cada vez más pequeños en el
denominador pues nuestra división va a
ser más grande así que si dividimos
entre números positivos cada vez más
pequeños todo esto se va a ser un número
más grande y bueno si esto va aumentando
y a esto además le agregamos 5 pues todo
esto va a estar incrementándose
se incrementa
y siempre va a suceder conforme x
disminuya pero permanezca positivo y
nuevamente podemos hacer una pequeña
tabla para comprobar que esto sucede así
aquí vamos a tener valores de x y aquí
vamos a tener nuestros 5 / x + 5 y para
x se me ocurre que voy a poner los
valores de 100 y después el de 5 y luego
un 1 así que es evidente que está x está
disminuyendo
aquí lo abrevió
y bueno si tenemos 5 / x x es 100 pues
tenemos 5 sobre 100 más 5 tendremos 5
puntos 0 5 ya que esto lo estoy dividido
entre 100 entonces me quedan 5
centésimas
cuando x es igual a 5 tendré 55 que es
igual a 1 así que tengo 15 pues aquí voy
a tener 6 y cuando x es igual a 1 voy a
tener 5 entre 1 que es lo mismo que 555
va a ser igual a 10 y así vemos que
mientras x sea positivo y este
decremento 'no sé' toda esta expresión 5
sobre x + 5 va a aumentar así que esto
de aquí se incrementa
y vamos a hacer otro problema más y aquí
voy a cambiar la variable ya no voy a
usar x digamos que tengo 3 y entre 2 y
yo me pregunto cómo se comporta esta
expresión conforme y se incrementa
y bueno conforme tengamos y es más
grandes en el numerador también
tendremos 10 más grandes en el
denominador una forma de pensar en ello
es que esto es igual a tres medios por g
sobre si iba imaginemos que estas nunca
llegan a ser ya que si la ley llegara a
ser cero esto ya sería una
indeterminación así que vamos a
especificar que ya se incrementa y que
ya es mayor que cero y bueno de hecho
aquí no importa que tengamos valor
positivo o negativo siempre y cuando no
sea cero
no importa qué valor tengamos de iu
tenemos entre iu y cualquier número
entre ese mismo número va a ser una
unidad va a ser 1 así que realmente no
nos importa qué valor tenga y puede ser
un millón entre un millón y va a seguir
siendo un 1 o una unidad podría ser 5
sobre 5 y esto no cambia así que el
valor de la expresión no va a cambiar si
yo modificó el valor de y así que esta
expresión no cambia
y cambia
siempre que ya sea positivo y sea
diferente de cero